[موسيقى] تم
الترحيب بها باعتبارها واحدة من
أخطر الأعمال المثيرة في تاريخ السينما.
توم كروز يخاطر بحياته وأطرافه بينما
إيثان هانت يتقدم بشكل أكبر وأكثر جرأة في
أحدث أفلام المهمة المستحيلة،
توقف طاقم العمل في أبو ظبي هذا
الأسبوع لحضور العرض الأول لفيلم الشرق الأوسط.
الدفعة السابعة من الحساب الميت، الجزء
الأول يا توم كروز، لقد أمضيت للتو ما يقرب من
ساعة مع المعجبين وهو
أسلوب توم كروز النموذجي الرائع للغاية
وهم في حالة من المتعة عندما
يتم إطلاق هذا الفيلم، وليس أقلها رؤيتك
في أكبر أعمالك المثيرة على الإطلاق  إذا لم تكن واحدة من
أكبر الأعمال السينمائية المثيرة على الإطلاق، نظرت
في عيني وأخبرتني أنك لم تكن
خائفًا من ذكائك، لا أستطيع
الفرق هو أنني فقط لا
أمانع في ذلك، كما تعلم أنني لا أمانع ذلك  هذا
الشعور يعجبني نوعًا ما هذا الشعور الذي أحب
رؤيته وكأنك تعلم أنك تستعد
لشيء ما وأنت مثل ما
سيحدث، لا أمانع هذا
الشعور هل هناك أي شيء لن
تفعله، لا أعرف، لا أعرف  "لا أعلم أنك تعلم أن
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي مازلت
أرغب في القيام بها
[موسيقى]
كيف تتحدى نفسك كنت
أتحدث إلى شخص ما قبل هذه
المقابلة وقالوا استمع إنه
لا مثيل له في هذه المرحلة من يتحدى من
يتحدىك توم كروز أنا  أنا دائمًا
أنا دائمًا طوال حياتي، أريد فقط أن
أسعى إلى التميز، أنا دائمًا كما
قلت، هناك دائمًا قصة أخرى
لأرويها، هناك دائمًا جبل آخر يجب
تسلقه، وأشعر دائمًا أنني أستطيع القيام
بذلك بشكل أفضل
وعلى الطريق الصحيح.  حافة مقاعدهم حتى
صديق الرحلات البحرية منذ فترة طويلة ومخرج الفيلم الذي نال
استحسانا كبيرا كريستوفر
ماكواري
ليس لدي ذكريات واضحة عنه،
كان هناك شخص ما يسجله وانتهى به الأمر
على الإنترنت، لذا أعرف الآن
كيف أبدو وكأنني
يختلف كثيرًا في رأسي عما يبدو عليه في الواقع
من الخارج، على ما يبدو أنني كنت
متوترًا جدًا، هل صحيح أنه كان
المشهد الأول الذي قمت بتصويره فقط في
حالة عدم نجاحك، وليس في حالة
عدم نجاحك، كما نحب فقط
لإخراج الأشياء الكبيرة من الطريق،
والأهم من ذلك أننا نود أن نعرف نوع
الفيلم الذي نصنعه والذي تم إنجازه، لذا فإن
إخراجه من الطريق هو
مجرد راحة كبيرة للتركيز على القصص
[موسيقى]
ما حجم الصفقة التي سيعمل معها، ما
حجم الصفقة التي سيعمل معها،
إذا كنت أفهم قصدك بشكل صحيح، فمن
المدهش أنه ليس بالأمر الكبير، أه
شخصي جدًا، أنيق للغاية
ومرتبط بشكل كبير ليس فقط ببقية الأشخاص
طاقم الممثلين ولكن بالنسبة للطاقم احتياجاتهم
ومشاعرهم فهو منتج بالإضافة إلى أنه
نجم الفيلم وهذا
يجعل الجميع يشعرون
براحة شديدة. هذه هي المرة الثالثة التي
يتم فيها تصوير السلسلة في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في عام 2010 استضافت دبي  مغامرة كروز المذهلة التي
تتسلق برج
خليفة أثناء تصوير Ghost Protocol
في عام 2021 في ذروة الوباء، تم
تصوير طاقم الفيلم في
صحراء ليوارد في أبو ظبي بالإضافة إلى صالة المطار في
مطار أبو ظبي الدولي،
وقد حقق المسلسل
نجاحًا دوليًا مذهلاً  أكثر من
3.5 مليار دولار في شباك التذاكر في جميع أنحاء العالم، من المقرر أن يتم
طرح الجزء الأول من الحساب الميت على مستوى العالم في منتصف شهر يوليو،
ويومئ الممثلون برأسهم إلى المزيد في المستقبل،
أنا في عمر توم 61 تقريبًا ولديه
هالة كاملة تبلغ 25 عامًا  يبلغ من العمر عامًا، لذا
أعتقد أنه سيقفز من الأشياء عندما يبلغ
100 عامًا.
هانت الأجنبي، هل هذه أغنية البجعة الخاصة به يا سيدي، سأتحدث
معك في الصيف المقبل،
شكرًا لك